thank you for coming to this talk in the
afternoon on the second day of the
conference part of this whole Norwegian
Developers Conference it is really
interesting to talk with people here I
am NOT a developer I am a mathematician
and I use all kinds of tools from
computer science and modern web
development etc but only if I need to do
something so I'm here basically because
I like to learn from people what you do
but also because data is everywhere like
I've talked with people here who do
back-end stuff usually that's managing
data right you do front-end stuff often
it's providing some interface for data
so that other folks in your company can
look at what the metrics are for this or
that manage reports and analytics so if
data is everywhere and it's changing how
everybody does their job this topic
might be of some interest to you but
it's also just for fun I'll start with
an overview of machine learning actually
because that is the buzzword of the day
and because this topic of topological
data analysis fits near machine learning
right even if you don't do machine
learning you've heard about it there
have been a lot of good talks here
DevOps for machine learning this morning
Damian Brady and bias and machine
learning yesterday arts doler
and there's a lot that machine learning
can do for you and a lot that it is
hyped to do that it can't actually do so
one of the things that I have found is
that machine learning people think you
put in your data and you get out answers
that are correct however that happens
and that's just not not true and I want
to differentiate this topological data
analysis this this way of exploring data
from machine learning because you don't
get
an answer by putting in data you get
information and so although we'll talk a
little bit about machine learning to put
this in context one of the messages that
I have for you for folks who are curious
about machine learning is that I think
the future is not that the machines will
just decide things for us but that we
will have machine assisted human
intelligence and I'll show you what I
mean in some of these examples machine
assisted human intelligence not
artificial intelligence just solve all
the problems in the world so here's a
really big top-down view of a few
features in machine learning so first of
all you've got to think about the kinds
of data you have structured data and
unstructured data unstructured data you
can get blog posts files of audio from
people talking peoples video content all
kinds of stuff that is not easy to put
into columns in a spreadsheet for
instance and that's probably 80% of the
data out there that's what I've heard
and then there's structured data you can
put it into columns in a spreadsheet
in essence it's easy to put into a
structured database and that's what will
essentially concentrate on today because
it's a little bit easier to work with
then after that big overview of
structured data versus unstructured data
we zoom in on the structured and we look
at supervised versus unsupervised
machine learning so supervised machine
learning is what a lot of you have
encountered for instance you have a lot
of historical data about good periods
for your company's products and bad
periods for your company's products you
have sales data for instance and you
look at all the other factors that can
go into that and you make a model like
oh if I change these things then I will
have better sales potentially or you
work backwards to say why did I have bad
sales this year maybe it's because of
this but you have some output that
you're fitting a model to
in supervised machine learning or you
feed a date all these cat versus dog
pictures on the Internet
right there are all these machine
learning algorithms that are learning to
recognize pictures and they started by
used using labelled data so you feed in
a thousand images of cats and dogs
labeled by undergraduates who got paid
seven dollars an hour in a work study to
label images or these days Facebook is
taking all of your pictures of your
friends that you have labeled with their
names and it is training on that data so
regression classification these are
classic supervised machine learning
techniques and we know that the world
does not have all kinds of high quality
labeled data and sometimes in fact you
want to find patterns in your data that
no one knows about yet
like sure you can identify cats and dogs
but what are the features that you may
never have thought of that you might
want to discover in a data set so that's
where we go over to unsupervised
learning and then in really small
letters in the bottom data mining data
mining is kind of an old-fashioned thing
at this point but it has never gone away
it's not the buzzword anymore but data
mining is this idea of getting insights
from data in many different ways and
then up unsupervised learning is about
using a lot of particular techniques
whether it be eventually neural networks
and things like that or other tools like
dimension reduction singular value
decomposition and principal component
analysis or clustering or manifold
learning so I'm not going to mention a
lot of algorithm names for clustering
manifold learning that sort of thing I
don't think that's the important part
right now but what I want you to think
about is the shape of data some things
are really linear systems like you can
do a linear dimension reduction and and
just figure out like oh yeah if I want
to look at
tech stocks then I just need to look at
the prices of Microsoft Amazon Apple
Netflix and Facebook and then I will
have essentially all the information
about that that small part of the sector
like you can reduce a lot of things to a
linear relationship and in that case we
have linear algebra you can do that
sometimes you have clunky data so you
can use unsupervised learning for
instance for clustering and you can
discover that there are different groups
in your data that are sort of
disattached from each other right here's
something here here's something here hmm
maybe I'm you know classifying the sizes
of grains of wheat like I was looking at
a data set recently that really just had
information about sizes of grains of
wheat and you could see clearly that
there were several different varieties
just by using clustering okay there's
three kinds of wheat manifold learning
sometimes there's an underlying shape to
what you have that lies in some space so
if you're looking for instance at a
robotic arm and where it can go it can
only get certain places in the space
because it can't move everywhere it's
constrained by its angles and then the
topic today is topological data analysis
which is a little bit different than all
of those things and the reason is that
topology does not care about distances
all the rest of these they put they're
looking for a structure in the geometry
like you have a manifold in this space
you have clusters here topology is a
little different because it doesn't care
about distances per se it only cares
about relationships and sometimes that's
a good way to look at things so
distances yeah this is the classic
picture for a topology a coffee cup and
a doughnut are the same to a topologist
because you can transform one from from
one to the other without ripping
anything you're not tearing any holes
you're just stretching there's no gluing
there's no ripping you're not changing
some important features of the data that
topologist care about which is the
number of holes the relationships of all
of these points to each other so that's
a good place to start if you take only
that away then you probably know more
about topology than the vast majority of
people on this planet but how do you do
that with data like how does that make
sense data comes in lines in a
spreadsheet or a CSV file so I was
raised as a pure mathematician and there
you have beautiful objects idealized you
do not need to do any data processing in
computer graphics and stuff you can use
some of those ideas and discretize it
that's fine now you have a donut over
there that's sort of discretized you
have points on its surface but that is
not how real data comes when you're
doing data analysis instead you have
something more like this this is the SP
500 stocks over a period of years and
how how they are in relationship to each
other
so that's a dimension reduction I've got
500 stocks but I squished it down to the
two most important dimensions in terms
of variants in their stock prices that
is not that's not beautiful
well it's ggplot in R but it's still not
that great right how do you see any
structure in that I mean I colored every
stock by its sector and you can kind of
see there are globs of of green on the
top I think that's like mineral and
mining companies and then there's like a
cluster of financial stuff but it
doesn't separate nicely into clusters
the way you think it should so the idea
here is that if we want to care about
the shape then we need to build a graph
on the data and look at look at the
rules
then that the the data obeys on that
graph essentially so this is these are
called simplices basically you're going
to connect the dots on your data that's
all and once you have that graph
structure you can look at the properties
of the graph there's been a lot of
social network analysis and graph stuff
but this is a little bit different
because it looks at some of the higher
dimensional components so we really care
about like when a piece in your point
cloud is connected to like five other
pieces as opposed to just one other
piece so like how many neighbors does
every point have how are they connected
and what I'm going to concentrate on
today is how that can help you with
visualization in particular we can and
you can ask me about some of these other
stuff too but today I'm going to
concentrate on visualization it looks
better on the screen you know then some
of the time series stuff that we could
do so I think I'm gonna start with a
little bit of financial data just to
talk about some of the messy stuff that
you can get into and then I'll talk
about some health data and and you
should ask questions if you have
questions along the way and if you want
afterwards I have some slides about how
you quantify this stuff for predictive
modeling but it's just not quite as as
pretty so presumably you're here because
you are interested in what developers
are interested in either you're a dev or
you just care about what does do so I
got a disclose what I use there is a
company called IOC out in Palo Alto that
is a great startup that does this stuff
they have a beautiful setup that's
proprietary and I can't afford so I
don't use that I use Python nice are I'm
at a State University so there are some
really nice packages for Python and for
our that help you
you both do the analysis and the
visualization there are some drawbacks
of course to all of these things I'll
show you some of the the good the bad
and the ugly along the way so for
visualization I want to tell you about
an algorithm called mapper which is like
the slogan at the top slice then cluster
then connect is really the key you have
some huge data set high dimensional you
want to see the structure of it somehow
you know it's not a good cluster sort of
thing it's not some robot arms locations
it's not a easy manifold structure you
don't know what's there you want to do
some basic unsupervised exploration see
what the data tells you
and so this mapper algorithm basically
says decide on your your metrics slice
up your data cluster on each slice and
then connect the clusters according to
whether they're overlapping so you're
gonna slice into overlapping pieces
cluster use k-means DB skin whatever you
want to use play with that and here's a
quote from the original paper that
introduced this that was not done by me
that's by all these folks Kunar
Carlson's at Stanford I can't remember
where his brother is
Michael vegetable johansen Gurjeet thing
a few of these folks started this
startup asti and then others are at
places like Intel and stuff like that
but you see the idea here like a hand
you can't do clustering on a hand and
get much sensible stuff out of it and
it's also not just like the shape the
fact that it has five fingers really
matters right so if you slice into these
overlapping pieces cluster and then
connect you can get this skeleton on the
bottom that tells you about the real
structure of your data set
and it preserves these important
features like there are fingers there's
also a poem so somehow I like this
technique there's you know plenty of
techniques to analyze your data but I
like this for certain kinds of high
dimensional data sets because it really
gives you something in between
continuous and discrete it really
distills down the structure of your data
to some sort of shape that then you can
ask questions about so let's see um I
was looking recently at the MSCI EAFE ax
it is an index of like 700 stocks from
Europe Asia and the Far East and somehow
I can't get HTML to embed in PowerPoint
so if you look at these 700 stocks you
can look at the correlations between
their returns and you can make a graph
like I will I will draw edges only
between stocks that are highly
correlated like they're moving together
over time let's draw a graph and this is
is trying to be too too clever for its
own good
this is using d3 and if you hover it'll
light up that part of the graph you can
see that it's having a little trouble
it's also a 700 node graph so it's kind
of big but you can see that this has
what they called a hairball problem like
when it when it lights up you can see
that it's just a ball of stuff you can't
understand anything from it it just is
is an enormous mess and so what I want
to show you is that with Grapher ignore
the stuff on the left I was trying to
color by sector and stuff like that and
it's it's not quite displaying right but
this is the same data organized in a
different way so this map or algorithm I
took myself
hundred stocks in some space and I
sliced it up looking at correlation
between them as my metric and clustered
and then you can see that there's much
much like this is one set of stocks a
ton of Hong Kong stocks like primarily
Asian stocks here and then this is
another set of stocks really clustered
together as you go over here there's
more european stocks so it's I think
although d3 is not being my friend here
in this in this large context this is a
much more refined structure and you can
look at each of these clusters by
themselves and say why are these
connected why are these connected what
do these have in common and so what
we're working on right now is analyzing
you know by by company by country by
sector all of this kind of information
by fundamental information when it comes
to stocks what what this structure comes
from and the thing that I'm particularly
interested in for this is the structure
over time as we have crashes and
recoveries in the economy rate so that's
700 stocks I used in network deep d3
this is what it looks like in a graph in
R it is not pretty I gotta say my graph
is a great package but it's ugly so I
haven't done all the analysis that I
want to do on this particular set of 700
stocks but you can see that you get a
structure out of mapper that is useful
potentially I'll show you a more cleaned
up example this is something we've been
working on for a while I've got a bunch
of colleagues in the School of Public
Health and the you it seems like
when I've talked a little bit about this
other places there are tons of people in
health care for instance who are trying
to do personalized medicine and stuff
like that you try to take data from
people's health records from their
devices all that sort of thing and
figure out how you can intervene to
prevent problems later this is a little
bit more old-school
it's a survey that started in 1997 you
filled it out with a pencil and all that
originally and it started by surveying
4,000 high school students in the Twin
Cities about their eating habits about
their activity their exercise levels how
their parents felt about weight and
mealtimes and things like this like an
incredible amount of data it is
structured so that's nice but it's got
all this psychological demographic and
and food data and the thing that I'm
working on with this team in the School
of Public Health is something called the
dieting paradox so we know that we know
that obesity is a problem in America
because it leads to health problems
right and so you should tell everyone to
diet and then they'll lose weight and
then we won't have health problems right
well that has not worked very well over
the years and there might be some
confusion of correlation and causation
here so it has not actually been proven
for instance that obesity is the result
rather than the cause or the cause
rather than the result of some of these
problems so one way to try to deal with
some of these public health problems is
to go back and look at people's actual
behavior because what like medical
professionals say when they say diet and
exercise
well what did teenagers actually do and
what did teenagers actually think you
know think back to when you were a
teenager you were probably
an average kid right most people are
basically average but your ideas about
what you should be or shouldn't be
influenced your actions and your ideas
about what you should or shouldn't be
especially with respect to health and
exercise and food may not be reflective
of reality right so what did teenagers
actually do some of them eat more
vegetables some of them just don't eat
breakfast some of them do a South Beach
diet some of them you know these days go
paleo or whatever some do the blood type
diet some of them every anyone heard of
this like lemon juice cleanse where you
only drink water with lemon juice and
cayenne pepper see there's always a few
people who not like maybe you haven't
done it but that's what people do and
that is not what your doctor is telling
you to do when they are telling you to
do diet and exercise right so the
observed problem on a public health
level with telling people to diet is
that for a substantial percentage of the
population it leads to bad outcomes
weight gain and mental health problems
for some people it works really well why
does it work for some people and why
does it actually make some people's
lives worse that's what we're trying to
figure out it's a big goal but let's
look at our data we have these 4,000
students who filled out all this stuff
and linear methods just fail you know
you can do all the principal component
analysis and projection you want and I
will like write about that a little bit
but the problem with looking at the
people side of things is that most
people are average and you just can't
tell that much it's a very high
dimensional data set and you just can't
differentiate between people by taking a
linear slice of your data on the left
and on the right I was looking here at
doing a singular value decomposition on
weight control baby
like unhealthy weight control behaviors
and it picks out fasting and then use of
laxatives to lose weight which are not
that common but the reason it fixed
those out is that they're the highest
variance behaviors they're the ones
where you have the highest variance in
the population because they're rare so
that's also not useful for a public
health perspective why are you gonna
just pick on a few rare things when
we're trying to look at the big picture
so this is where TDA comes in and I
think it's been really useful here we
haven't written a paper yet but we're
working on it so I have a 38 dimensional
point cloud with 4,000 points in it
those 4,000 people and 38 demographic
psychological psychosocial dimensions so
you decide how to measure distance
there's a couple of ways to do it you
slice a cluster you draw edges and you
get some real structure so this is only
looking at boys I have the slides for
girls too if you want afterwards but I
think looking at teenagers this is kind
of instructive there are two thousand
three hundred and seventy seven unique
boys in this sample
I'm sliced it into the data into 16
pieces do the clustering draw lines
between them if there's overlap
unfortunately I think I need to darken
the lines here because there are lines
maybe you can see them all along here so
it's like there's a big backbone here
that's connected and then there's a hole
here and then I colored it by percentile
BMI so red is higher percentile BMI and
Green is lower percentile BMI here and
that's for each cluster and this
visualization right here you see that
there's a structure in this data like I
didn't
okay there are a lot of variables I
didn't include here BMI is one of them
but it's one of 38 and still there's
this high BMI area medium BMI next to it
low BMI on the other end so that's
interesting does it really matter does
this really give us anything so let's
look at some behavioral variables this
is actually whether you're trying to
gain or lose weight with one of the
survey questions and I think the naive
public health approach at this point is
like Oh everyone's trying to lose weight
right but that's not true for instance
and this is one reason I bring up
teenage boys not all teenage boys are
trying to lose weight many are trying to
gain weight so this is coloring by the
proportion of boys who want to gain
weight so in this higher BMI group boys
don't want to gain weight in the lower
BMI group there are some clusters in
particular where like kids really are
trying to gain weight and then I think
here's a trying to gain weight cluster
as well but I think the motivations for
trying to gain weight here and here are
different so there's like the boys who
are pretty low weight and are trying to
gain weight just because that's what
they want to do and then there's the
kids in sports who are like I need to
make a certain weight class or something
like that you can start to see this if
you go a little further this is boys
trying to lose weight over here boys are
trying to lose weight and no one else is
really trying to lose weight so that's
not really the the focus we should have
maybe and then if we look at dieting
frequency dieting frequency in guys only
a small percentage of these guys diet
too
lose weight right so there are other
behavioral variables that play this one
confirmed binge eating disorder and you
can see that it's very rare except for
two groups and then we can go back dig
into the data and wonder why like here
on the lower end it makes sense to me
that there's binge eating disorder
confirmed in this group because they're
a group of guys who are dieting a lot
and those behaviors are correlated in
the literature but why up here these
guys aren't dieting so that's something
to figure out this is body
dissatisfaction and look it's not the
high BMI guys who are the most
dissatisfied it's the low beaten BMI
guys and then you can go to most
satisfied these guys are most satisfied
with their bodies they were just in the
middle and then you go to exercising a
lot oh the guys who exercise more than
16 hours a week also tend to be the most
satisfied whoa
this is interesting and then people who
exercise less than six hours a week so
you can go through all your variables
and just light up the hot spots and try
to figure out using domain expertise
what's going on
so in this particular setup what we did
was you know I sat down with some
dietitians and nutritionists Public
Health types and just eyeballed it
honestly like where would you draw the
lines for this group versus this group
let's go analyze it this is not machine
learning at this point this is machine
aided human intelligence right we're
using this for a feature discovery we're
trying to pick out what in the data
might be a driver and how we can set up
a model after that so
and just to just to lend some credence
to this even though we did eyeball the
groups they're statistically different
significantly different you know that's
kind of fun
so there's a little bit of just playing
with the data this is almost like
exploratory data analysis at this point
and I think that this is useful because
it allows you to disentangle the
correlations and in in various groups if
you just look at average --is of your
data you do not see the shape
you just see one number right here on
the other hand you can see that on a
public health level it's the people who
are winning a particular group of young
men who don't exercise very much don't
think weights important don't stress
about it and don't do anything like at
all they don't do the good things they
don't do the bad things they don't have
any of those problems and yet it's the
the and the very active kids of course
do very well as well but it seems that
maybe caring too much actually can be a
problem
don't take any public health advice from
me but you know just look at the data
it's interesting so these are
statistically too significant groups and
this is I think where we then take these
insights back the feature discovery put
them into traditional statistical models
or agent-based modeling that's one thing
that we're looking at I don't know if
you've heard about that just to model
what will happen in the future you so
who knows the difference between machine
learning and modeling so machine
learning you put in your data and you do
some learning on it and maybe it's in
their own network and you cannot explain
anything about how it works but it gives
you an answer right
you need tons of data to train that
neural network and then it can do a very
good job sometimes right modeling on the
other hand F equals MA right force
equals mass times acceleration that's a
model did you need tons of data to
figure that out
yeah people did use data to figure it
out but at some point you can create a
model from domain expertise without
having data you used data to test your
model and so this is part of a big cycle
in machine learning use machine learning
to discover features bring the features
back create a model then test your model
and iterate through that process over
over time so at this point I will ask
you which direction do you want to go do
you want to talk about how to make this
quantitative for modeling or do you want
to look at more pictures pictures
pictures let's see
[Music]
let's let's look at the the girls
behavioral stuff for the moment so where
would you put the group's here what's
different and what's the same
okay that one told you my groups
although it's upside down so this is
girls and percent percentile BMI so
there's a lower BMI backbone again and a
higher BMI part of the backbone and then
this this end is different than for
girls and guys somehow to me this is
percentage of girls trying to gain
weight like girls in high school are not
trying to gain weight by and large
there's like twenty who are in my sample
trying to lose weight wow that's a lot
and in particular at this end so I think
what's interesting this is the high
dieting frequency end as well and this
is the eating disorders and and this is
the never exercising less than four
hours a week and this is exercising
thirteen hours a week or more so I think
what's interesting is that girls and
guys are really differentiated by the
way that exercise versus gaining weight
plays in to what they think this is a
graph of depression so unfortunately
dieting frequency and depression like
perfectly correlated and girls so if you
split them up you can really see a
different pattern of of movement for
girls if you are I just look at the
diets per year column if you can see
that the highe dieting group is like 15
or more diets a year and then there's
again the I don't exercise and I don't
do anything and I do okay group at less
than one diet a year like there's a huge
heterogeneity in in how people approach
all of this stuff right
and I think it's very useful to be able
to look at it on a continuum not just in
in in averages in population numbers you
got to be able to pick out the different
structures this is one cool thing I took
those same people carried them forward
15 years and the differences persist and
people are basically doing pretty
similar things as they did in high
school like our habits are set in many
ways when we're young so any any
questions or anything you want to go
back to in there
mm-hmm yeah it's all--it's um
unfortunately it's because it's not
machine learning per se it's not covered
in any of those classes but it's applied
math not pure math so it's not taught in
topology classes either so it's gonna
take a while to make it into the
curriculum that you need for any
graduation requirements and there are
some great tutorials online but you have
to look for them you have to know
exactly you know the name that you're
looking for so let's go back to this
picture for a minute here is the the
hand you to go into a little bit more
detail there the color on there is
actually useful the red to blue on the
hand that's some metric that you put on
and you've got to have some filter
function so you choose some sort of
function whether it's low correlation to
high correlation or if you have some
average value that you're interested in
of something you pick a metric like that
and you put a filter on it and you slice
according to that so I've also used
Princeton standard deviation from the
mean that's a good a good metric to
slice along here it's just right to left
which is pretty nice and so you take
whatever filter function you have here
right to left and you choose the number
of intervals along there that you want
so for a lot of the images that you saw
for for the eating stuff that was 16
intervals just 16 evenly spaced
intervals along whatever metric you
chose and you slice up the data and just
look at each alone so you look at one
slice alone like here 1 2 3 4 4
different clusters on this slice which
is why you get
two three four four different notes you
notice that this hand is longer than
this one and that's because each slice
overlaps with each other slice so you
have to have overlay overlap so that you
can draw the connecting parts so here
one two three three clusters here are
four clusters these two have overlap so
you draw this line these two have
overlap so you draw this edge and so on
and everything
for instance in here overlaps with the
one cluster that's yellow so that's how
you get the four edges coming to that
one one yellow spot there is a lot of
art rather than science at this point to
some of this like that that's a well
developed algorithm but you can use
whatever clustering algorithm you want
within it so it shouldn't change your
results too much in my experience but
you can use DB scanner k-means yeah
there's a couple other that are easy to
use so this is all implemented in
something like it's the mapper algorithm
but it's implemented in both R and in
Python under that name and there's an
effort to build a whole library that
brings topological methods to in a
scikit-learn kind of style so you can
use Sai kit TDA that's what they're
they're calling it so it's not machine
learning so it's not scikit-learn but
it's I kid TDA my advice is is are easy
to get up and running very quickly
Python gives you ultimate control of
course that's the that's the trade-off
yeah any other questions
ah so I dropped a lot of things actually
when I was doing this clustering so I'll
bring bring this question picture back
so when I was looking at this I have a
huge file like thousands of columns of
data but what I did for to create this
is I dropped race citizenship
socioeconomic status
I kept gender that's actually really
useful to differentiate by in this case
and I then only kept these psychological
variables exercise related variables and
caloric intake things like that so I
tried to drop as much as I could to
build on only a subset of data so that
we could test these other traits against
it and see if there's any value to a
predictive value essentially this is a
hard thing I think in in in TDA and this
is again going back to that machine
assisted human intelligence you have to
decide what you think will show you this
structure and try it there and then you
need some way of testing it you can find
patterns in anything if you just apply
the right algorithms or enough of them
so here we wanted to really look at
behavioral and psychological variables
only and see then if these other if they
could predict essentially some of these
other outcomes so you have to decide
what's your what's your input and what
you want to test it against as an output
and I don't think I included age for
instance but there are some age of
differences in the groups so there's
it's it's showing some value in picking
out predictive factors but you have to
you can't put those in if you want to
predict them right so that's that's
of the back-and-forth that you need to
do with your domain expert like it's the
public health people who help decide
what to put in and what to try to
predict they've done some really cool
analysis with genetic data in particular
so there are a bunch of papers that look
at diabetes for instance and what they
do is they take only clinical
presentations of people coming in with
problems with their diabetes only
clinical stuff like oh I have an eye
problem because of my diabetes
oh I'm experiencing neuropathy because
of my diabetes I have heart problems and
I have diabetes and they did TDA only on
those clinical presentations and then
they overlaid people's genetic
information on it in the study and you
can see that there are different genes
involved in certain outcomes so that's
pretty cool like working backwards from
the clinical presentation to the genes
that maybe have something to do with it
so you have to decide what you want your
input to be and what you want to test it
against and essentially as an output
other questions I'm available to chat
afterwards too if you want to if you
want to chat so I have many pictures and
you should just let me know if you want
to look at them so oh I question I have
to put up my funding acknowledgments so
oh this is this is an interesting
question so first of all I will say that
I have a couple Jupiter notebooks and
things like that and in fact an hour
notebook on my binder org I don't know
if you've ever heard of this so that you
could play with it like now without me
installing everything those are set up
though with fake data that's small so
that you can just play with it without
challenging your computational
capacities so one really nice set to try
first is actually the Wisconsin breast
cancer set so this is a classic machine
learning set that's widely available
freely available from the UCI machine
learning repository for instance so if
you look up with Wisconsin breast cancer
UCI machine learning it'll come up and
basically what that data set has is a
lot of features of a biopsy of a tumor
so it's got tumor size and like how how
furry the edges there's a technical term
for that but then it also is it's a
labeled set it has whether the tumor is
benign or malignant and you can do TDA
on the tumor characteristics leaving off
the classification of course and you
will see that there's a real striking
pattern there it's it's it was one of
the first test cases that they used sort
of as a proof of concept
and it's worked really well I think
health data works really well I've done
it with some of these diabetes data sets
that are available freely you can see
type one diabetes type two diabetes and
normal like as three arms of a Y
basically so that's kind of cool so
health data that's freely available is
where I'd go first but I will say that's
one of the reasons I did all this stock
market stuff that's really available
from Yahoo Finance so it's not always
good data but it's it's free yeah I will
be sharing a lot of this on my github
page so you can always check out code
examples there yeah well thank you and I
think it's time for afternoon tea now
[Applause]